220 milliards de dollars et généralisé
n'a pas su proposer et se trouve très
isolés dès lors relations avec le
parlement sont en bon jusqu'à contester
le système présidentiel dans son entier
l'un d'eux le député cunha bueno a même
proposé une solution radicale qui a fait
l'effet d'une bombe
il faut dit-il restaurer lent qu'il est
contre toute attente le congrès a voté
en faveur d'un référendum sur la
monarchie
aucun système n'est parfait mais une
j'ai pris 10 le mels arésiens meilleur
qu'une république des finances yannis
tafer comme les descendants de pedro
deux derniers empereurs brésilien se
disputent déjà son trône perdu en 1889
aujourd'hui les prétendants ne serait
que deux le premier le thrace don pedro
frère cadet de la comtesse de paris
il vit aujourd'hui au palais impérial de
petropolis près de rio
on arrivera une stabilité politique dans
ce pays avec l'événement de la monarchie
le deuxième prétendant jean d'orléans
bragance plus jeunes n'est autre que le
neveu de don pedro
le français bertrand renouvin parle de
ceux qui parmi les brésiliens sont le
plus séduit par la monarchie dans le
peuple et notamment chez les noirs il y
à vif intérêt pour cette solution dans
la musique la monarchie brésilienne
avait a franchi les esclaves à la
famille alors de 13 ans 1993
les brésiliens décideront s'ils veulent
garder leur président et leur république
ou s'ils souhaitent un empereur est une
monarchie constitutionnelle et de marc
le monde verra peut-être pour la
première fois un empereur danser la
samba